[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be doing
something a little bit different now
i've done ranking videos in the past
mainly focusing on things that are
powerful but what i haven't done yet is
step too far outside of this realm
focusing on power with that said today i
want to look at in my opinion the 10
saddest moments from the harry potter
series number 10 hermione wiping her
parents memories near the beginning of
harry potter and the deathly hallows
part 1 the wizarding world was in
turmoil the imminent threat of voldemort
in the death eaters meant that not only
witches and wizards were in danger but
muggles too
knowing that the danger would eventually
stretch beyond the confines of the
wizarding world hermione granger knew
that she would have to make a difficult
choice a choice involving her parents
effectively what hermione needed to do
was erase her parents memories this
would disassociate them from her and
possibly save their lives as they
couldn't possibly reveal information
about someone that they had never met in
this horrifyingly sad moment hermione
erased every memory that they ever had
of her what made this moment even sadder
was that hermione was completely unsure
if she would ever see them again number
nine cedric's death now whether you're a
film goer or a book reader the untimely
death of cedric diggory was no doubt
impactful it happened during the third
challenge of the triwizard tournament
just after harry and cedric
simultaneously clutched the triwizard
cup unbeknown to them however the
triwizard cup was actually a portkey a
port key that sent them straight to
wormtail voldemort and the little
hangleton graveyard it was here that
cedric lived out his final moments
ultimately reaching his fate at the
hands of peter pettigrew and his killing
curse the goblet of fire was dark it was
made abundantly clear that voldemort had
in fact returned and hogwarts the
wizarding world lost the life of a
promising young wizard that stood for
what was right what made cedric's death
even more sad was witnessing his father
amos diggory realizing that his son whom
he was immensely proud of had in fact
passed away number 8 draco malfoy's
breakdown now draco malfoy isn't exactly
the typical type of character that you'd
feel sorry for right from the beginning
of the books films draco exhibits
questionable behavior he is the
archetypal bully and this bullying only
intensifies over the years as he
develops into a young man as draco grows
older we witness firsthand his evolution
from petulant but innocent little boy to
sinister and dark young man what really
set him off was the imprisonment of his
father after the battle of the
department of mysteries a battle that
effectively served as the catalyst and
first major conflict of the second
wizarding war from that point onward
draco felt the immense pressure and
burden of living up to the malfoy family
name this meant becoming a death eater
and serving the dark lord this also
meant that he was tasked with killing
dumbledore however in the half blood
prince it becomes abundantly clear that
draco has a lot of internal conflict he
doesn't want to do these things or
become this person but he feels that he
has to but it is his duty in one
particular scene in the half blood
prince we see all of these conflicting
emotions at play a scene where draco
lets it all come out as he cries alone
in the boy's bathroom unsure of what he
has become
in this scene i couldn't help but feel
sorry for the boy that was just raised
the wrong way the boy who didn't want to
be banned but never had a choice number
seven hedwig's death the death of an
animal companion is never easy one of
the reasons for this is that though you
are able to communicate with them on
some level it's hard to convey how you
truly feel hedwig was given to harry
right to the beginning of his journey
into the wizarding world and hedwig
stuck by harry's side through thick and
thin when harry was stuck at the
dursleys place on privet drive with no
one else to speak to hedwig was there
for him tragically in the battle of the
seven potters hedwig is killed while
aboard hagrid's flying motorcycle hit
with a killing curse the curse was
likely aimed at harry but hedwig took
the hit and harry felt guilty for this
what made things worse was that harry
then had to destroy the sidecar carrying
hedwig in order to better escape the
death eaters the death of hedwig is
sudden tragic and life-changing for
harry hedwig's death was almost symbolic
for the loss of innocence in the harry
potter films number six dumbledore dies
as we know dumbledore dies in the half
blood prince this scene is perhaps more
shocking than sad to most as dumbledore
was was portrayed as this sort of beacon
of hope of power dumbledore always has
all of the answers and if things go awry
you can always count on dumbledore but
suddenly in the blink of an eye the
seemingly omniscient hogwarts headmaster
that you can always count on is gone of
course we sort of knew that dumbledore
was going to die and that he was
incredibly ill from the curse on his
hand but it just somehow didn't feel
real dumbledore is certainly a fan
favorite and to suddenly lose this
beloved hogwarts headmaster just felt
wrong
the absence of dumbledore in the story
was incredibly apparent and it left the
harry potter world feeling a bit vacant
number five sirius dies sirius black
friend of harry's parents and harry's
godfather was tragically killed in the
order of the phoenix more specifically
he died during the battle at the
department of mysteries an important
battle and one of the primary catalysts
of the second wizarding war just two
short books prior harry and sirius were
first introduced and from harry's
perspective sirius went from murderer
and azkaban escapee to one of the most
important people in his life his death
was tragic because for so many years
sirius wanted to reach harry but was
unable the pair though close spent a
relatively small amount of time together
but did form a strong bond in that short
period serious dying was terrible for
harry but what made it even worse was
that in a way he had lost another
connection to his parents number four
dobby's death this one doesn't need much
explaining the death of dobby was tragic
whichever way you look at it the
mistreated house elves that had finally
been liberated by harry potter would
have done anything for harry and he
really proved that when he took a knife
to the chest when everyone apparated out
of malfoy manor they landed at a beach
by shell cottage it was at this beach
that everyone realized dobby had been
hit with bellatrix's knife number three
snape's death for the vast majority of
the harry potter story snape is the bad
guy he looks round bullies students and
is particularly awful to harry this
treatment doesn't change over the years
either but perhaps only intensifies as
harry grows into a young man but what
many didn't know was that snape was a
double agent who was playing a part and
both sides were convinced that he was on
their side by the time snape dies we
become completely aware of his true
intentions and where his true
motivations lay however while we the
audience are aware of all of this harry
isn't to harry snape is still the
two-faced death eater that killed
dumbledore and swore his allegiance to
voldemort however after harry watches
snape being fatally attacked by nagini
something begins to change in harry's
mind snape was in a state unlike
anything that harry had ever seen before
the strong enigmatic snape was suddenly
so helpless and it's at this point the
idea is planted in harry's mind to
perhaps snape isn't quite as bad as he
thought after giving harry some of his
memories which will reveal to harry
snape's true motivations snape dies
looking into the eyes of a boy that was
more significant to him than harry ever
knew the boy that shared the same face
of the man that bullied him for his
entire childhood and the eyes of the
only woman that he ever loved number two
death of fred weasley in my opinion the
death of fred weasley twin brother to
george weasley is one of the saddest
moments in the entire series i say this
because twins share a special
relationship they're almost like one
person and so i can't begin to imagine
what looting your other half would be
like fred dies from an explosion outside
the room of requirement and it doesn't
take long for george to realize that his
world would be turned upside down their
friendship was beautiful and though
george still had the rest of his family
with him he certainly lost a piece of
himself that day i sincerely doubt that
he was ever the same
number one the end this might be a
cop-out but for me the saddest part of
the harry potter story was its end i'm
sure that i speak for many others as
well when i say that i wish the harry
potter story could continue forever what
are your top 10 saddest moments let me
know in the comment section below if you
enjoy the content please like the video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time it does not do to dwell on dreams
forget to live
[Music]
you